rescue workers battling poor visibility
as they continue to search a deep gorge
for passengers who are unaccounted for
rescued from the crash site the cockpit
voice recorder and the flight data
recorder investigators hope information
stored on these devices will help
determine what caused the yeti Airlines
plane to crash Witnesses are also being
interviewed
the plane flew above our heads and we
thought it was making a turn but we
noticed that the Rotator on the side was
not functioning and the aircraft looked
tilted as we were looking it first
crashed onto the right side of the cliff
and then broke into two halves
the plane went down on Sunday near
pakhara's New International Airport that
opened only two weeks ago it was
traveling from Kathmandu
it came to the side of my house after
bouncing back and then burst into flames
when we heard the sound we looked out
and saw a huge ball of fire in the air
and then we rushed out of our house
family of one of the victims were
inconsolable as they received the news
of his death
my son used to run a public service
center and provide for his family he was
the only earning member of the family
all the people in the village were proud
of him it's very sad I'm not able to
speak much
the air accident is the country's worst
in three decades a national day of
mourning is being observed Victoria
Gayton B Al Jazeera